Early stage entrepreneurship
is really hard.
You have to do everything.
And so, it's very easy to get off-track.
It's very easy to dive down into trying
to build the perfect marketing plan,
maybe we even don't have a product yet,
or
you can dive into the code of a product
making it perfect when it doesn't even
work yet, there's nothing to display,
nothing to show people.
So, as an entrepreneur,
the thing that you really have
to keep in mind is focus.
What are the things that you're focused
on that are going to make your business
move forward?
It may not be the things that
you want to work on today.
you think are the most fun.
But you have to constantly step back and
say,
okay, what is the most important thing I
need to do to move the business forward?
And focus on that.
And there are so many distractions, and
you just have to let yourself move
forward and not get sidetracked.